one in five people who are of working
age and perfectly fit and able to work
in our major cities do not work and are
paid by the state not to work well you
know there's many many times the
population of Britain in China who are
willing to work many many times what the
hardest working people in our society
work in order to get the lifestyle that
we seem to think is our right and it
isn't so I wish there was a little bit
more work alcoholism in the UK we could
do with it and we could do with a bit of
shaming actually of the people who just
want to put their feet up sit around and
eat Doritos until the perfect job comes
around because it's not going to